une grosse fête on était une trentaine
quoi les connaissances ou tu te sourire
tranquillement
ouais voilà on était content de le faire
c'est ça c'est normal tu arrives à
quelle heure toi moi je suis arrivé dans
les coins de
23h23h30
vraiment je suis arrivé un peu tard
ouais une autre soirée avant non même
pas mais juste chez moi ok
Rainbow Six pas mal ce soir il y a Rambo
dans la soirée visiblement donc grosse
soirée donc grosse fête donc il y a
beaucoup de bruit il y a du bruit
toi ta présence suffisait
ma présence était
là pour l'anniversaire de Tony c'est bon
quoi exactement ok
il y avait de l'alcool il y avait de
l'alcool
un petit coup et pas rentrer en voiture
après
comment il s'appelle Nathalie Natoo
dans les coins de 5h du mat elle est
venu chercher ta mère
franchement c'est un amour
je veux connaître ta mère déjà
donc toi
tu étais alcoolisé ou tu étais tu étais
pas un petit coup quand même un petit
coup quand même
rappelle que la vue d'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé t'étais bien
mais ta mère est venue te chercher
franchement j'avoue bravo Nathalie là
qu'est-ce qui se passe il y a une
bagarre qu'est-ce qui s'est passé déjà
pour la soirée déjà la soirée pourquoi
il y a une bagarre quoi alors c'est pas
une bagarre mais on connaît les soirées
souvent vers de 3h c'est assez par pi à
droite à gauche et on était beaucoup et
donc il y en a beaucoup qui étaient
devant dans leur voiture pour se faire
des cigarettes de tels qui parlent à
gauche non cigarette
dans les voitures
et donc ouais et donc
il y en a deux qui parlaient là de là de
là de là et ça faisait beaucoup de bruit
un peu devant la salle du coup on a
commencé à ramener tout le monde parce
que on voulait pas non plus le
bordel dans le dans la ville revenez
tous dans la salle donc voilà c'est ça
on a ramené un peu tout le monde
[Musique]
donc là les mecs dans la salle voilà il
y en a toujours un petit peu devant qui
a dit tu casses les couilles ça va il y
en a qui vient mais on arrive à ramener
tout le monde quand même ouais donc ça
donc tout le monde rentre donc la
trentaine tout le monde est encore là
ouais tout le monde était encore là
2h30 là les 30 personnes c'est
l'anniversaire voilà c'est ça donc là
tout le monde rentre dans la salle et là
quand on dit qu'il y a une bagarre qui
éclate c'est quoi la bagarre c'est pas
une bagarre c'est il y a deux personnes
forcément quand on est 30 que tout le
monde a bu il y a des conflits forcément
les gens s'entendent pas bien et avec
l'alcool c'est c'est encore pire donc ça
commence à hausser le ton un peu ça se
passe ça commence à hausser le ton mais
il y a deux personnes en particulier qui
se prennent un peu la tête pourquoi et
je sais franchement ça c'est cool ça
commence un peu non ça se pose pas parce
qu'on sait pas il y a du front contre
front non même pas non c'est juste on
les sépare bien sa gueule un peu à
gauche à droite machin truc et tout mais
ça crie mais il y a rien il y a pas de
il y a pas de coup il y a rien que ça va
pas partir
on fait attention quand même parce que
c'est vous êtes alcoolisé voilà c'est ça
le problème donc la gros bordel quand
même dans la soirée ouais ça ouais il y
a un peu le bordel quand même c'est on
est d'accord donc gros bordel dans la
soirée il est quelle heure là 2h30 voilà
donc les mecs qui est 2h30 donc bordel
dans la soirée il y a toujours de la
musique où il y a que le bordel on a
coupé un peu la musique on a coupé un
fond mais on vous êtes plus de bruit que
la musique quoi voilà c'est ça d'accord
c'est inspecteur à nous
donc tu as vu le témoignage du maire je
voudrais avoir maintenant ta version
parce que
là déjà là sa gueule de partout le mer
arrive donc le maire on l'a vu il a
l'air sympa il arrive en tong il est
arrivé en tombe donc il a des beaux
pieds
j'ai pas fait attention donc il arrive
en tong le maire donc là il arrive il
dit quoi alors il arrive il ouvre les
deux portes de l'entrée mais il arrive
presque violemment quoi il arrive avec
une autre personne ouais les gars
arrêtez j'ai appelé les flics vous avez
tous dégager
et ça crie et on dit quoi ouais ben
normalement dit vous allez tous dégager
bah moi je savais pas au début c'était
d'accord
tu dis ça oui oui je me suis dit
pourquoi il vient c'est qui ouais voilà
moi je savais pas au début c'est qui lui
genre je me suis battuce non plus mais
je me suis dit pourquoi il vient ouais
pourquoi il vient donc là on te dit
c'est le meilleur voilà c'est ça on me
dit après que c'est le maire d'accord ça
crée tout donc là c'est ce qui nous dit
parce que lui il a dit ouais j'arrive je
leur dis on arrête la musique tout ça là
mais il arrive un peu violemment genre
quoi bah genre il arrive il ouvre les
portes les gars vous avez tous dégagé
chacun rentre chez lui j'ai appelé les
flics vous allez voir agressant quoi bon
ça ça va ça va encore il était un gars
ouais d'accord donc là ok donc là vous
dites quoi donc on était dans une sorte
d'aller devant c'est un petit couloir et
on commence tout ça à aller devant lui
dans le couloir Olivier quoi au début ça
commence à dire pourquoi tu viens
pourquoi tu cries machin explique-nous
machin et le problème c'est que on était
30 dans le couloir ça commence à crier à
gauche à droite machin mais c'est encore
contrôlable au moment là mais genre ça
crée un peu agressif envers le maire bah
lui nous crie bien dessus agressif parce
que ce qu'il a pas dit c'est qu'il
sortait d'un apéro et qu'il a bien bu
juste avant
quoi le maire il était aussi torché tout
exactement en fait le hasard a fait que
donc là donc je fais la tête
exactement
en gros c'est ça quoi je te ramène tu es
mon frère non
mais
en gros l'histoire elle est comme ça
donc le bail c'est voilà il arrive on
tombe encore
[Musique]
c'est ta version c'est ça ouais voilà
c'est ça d'accord il était un apéro et
il était avec deux parents et leur fils
était avec nous d'accord vous savez
qu'il était un apéro qui avait donc le
fils a dit
il a dit il a dit ouais il sort d'un
apéro et puis si ça se sentait il
sentait un peu l'alcool il marchait plus
non franchement
donc là c'est deux donc un maire bourré
face à deux jeunes bourré c'est en fait
l'histoire elle est là donc
vous êtes bourré donc là qu'est-ce qui
se passe quand est-ce que ça part en
cacahuète ça part que on commence on est
les ils sont tous les deux là nous on
est là et il se passe que le maire et la
deuxième personne pousse un coup le
groupe il pousse le groupe pourquoi vous
vous l'accueillez ben en fait le
problème c'est que il y en a 30 il y en
a 10 derrière qui poussent pour savoir
ce qui se passe donc forcément voilà
c'est
laissez-nous et il pousse un gros coup
ouais et il y a une personne du groupe
qui est tombée de nos potes donc là ça
sent venime voilà c'est ça ça part de là
en fait ouais il tombe il y a une
personne dans la soirée qui voit ça et
en fait avec l'alcool elle réfléchit pas
elle réfléchit pas du tout et en fait
elle passe devant tout le monde arrive
devant le maire elle lui met une folie
voilà c'est de là que vient la
genre qui venait de nulle part voilà
elle vient de là donc de derrière ou de
devant
la tour de voir la personne arrive
c'est ça donc pour l'instant
excuse-moi je t'adore vraiment je
t'adore le seul truc qu'on avait pas
c'est qu'il est un peu beurré sinon il
nous a raconté à peu près la vérité donc
il a dit j'ai pris une explosif je sais
pas où elle Venise c'est en courant donc
c'est un gars on dira pas le gars mais
voilà le gars donc tu le connaissais le
gars qu'il avait une folie de vue de
vues comme ça d'accord et donc et donc
là il a pété un câble et donc qu'est-ce
qui se passe après la flogie ce qui se
passe c'est que nous on sait pas tout de
suite bah oui c'est grave on sait pas
direct parce que ça partait beaucoup
trop loin et donc là il fait quoi le
maire et le gars le maire et la deuxième
personne il sort de la salle exactement
ce que nous a dit donc le maire pour
l'instant
bourré il a pris le chiffre
il est dans le village tu vois il est
pas mal
c'est énorme
[Applaudissements]
ça arrive tout le temps et les fleuji
comme ça dans les soirées après il faut
pas le faire et surtout sur Monsieur le
Maire d'alcool et voilà exactement c'est
une catastrophe l'alcool c'est une
catastrophe voilà c'est ça en fait
l'histoire en vérité la morale de
l'histoire c'est que la colle c'est une
catastrophe alors dis-moi et en fait il
sort pas pour courir il se met devant la
salle donc nous on empêche tout le monde
de sortir pour pas que ça continue
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est normal mets-toi à sa place
tout le monde tu es dehors on tourne
frères quand même tu vas dire quoi tu
vas dire bon
c'est bon mais toi ça passe c'est normal
c'est normal le maire le pauvre il a été
il est sorti il est en apéro avec je
reviens dans 2 minutes il est tombé
il revient la gueule en bière c'est bon
je reviens je vais tuer on peut
comprendre donc là il est donc là il est
vénère il est vénère voilà il dit quoi
donc qui nous crie dessus vous allez
voir les filles qui arrivent vous êtes
mort machin normal et il y en a qui
arrive à passer tu en as qui arrive à
passer et le maire il a pas couru mais
en fait il marchait à l'envers
il y a une petite statue le maire il
s'est transformé Michael Jackson
[Rires]
autour il y avait une statue de vent et
il y a trois personnes qui le suivaient
on s'expliquer et lui il marchait à
l'envers ouais vous allez voir ma chance
et il était en claquette et il tombe
c'est normal et
donc claquette il tombe en arrière et
donc là il est beurré voilà il tombe il
tombe en arrière direct d'accord donc
tout de suite on sait pas ou qui reçoit
aucun coup quoi tu es sûr parce que ça
c'est chaud quand même ah oui mais ça
c'est sûr il a pas reçu des coups basket
il y en a pas 30 qui veulent pas
inquiète tapé le maire après à terme il
a peut-être pris un coup dans le pied à
la limite non mais on a séparé il a
jamais reçu
non mais il a jamais pris 40 coups il a
jamais il a été on a séparé tout de
suite
et c'est pareil c'est grave ce qui dit
mais on l'a pas quand il était parti
dans les fils qui dit s'il sa version
elle est vrai c'est grave bien sûr
normal mais il a quand même pris une
gifle
j'ai pas dit tout de suite mais on a
déjà séparé tout machin et puis je lui
ai dit que c'est pas possible tu peux
pas faire un truc comme ça bien sûr
surtout qu'en plus c'est le maire ou pas
même si c'est pas le miennes tu imagines
c'est sûr tu arrives sur la page tu mets
des Fruges à tout le monde c'est sûr
arrête non mais non c'est pas bien mais
dans ta version le maire donc ce qui
diverge de la version lumière ah il
était beurré deux il est tombé tout seul
bien sûr grâce à cause de sa tombe
en Moonwalk
3 il a peut-être pris un petit coup
Dieppe
un déferlement de toute façon on le voit
sur les images le il a été à l'hôpital à
3h du matin à 5h30 il est ressorti ta
mère elle était venu chercher à 5h
qu'est-ce que ça fait 3 heures à 5h toi
frère Ben il y avait il y avait plein de
fallait aller voir tout le monde il
fallait calmer les trucs il fallait
longtemps à 5h du matin me chercher
c'est bon il y a un gars qui a pris le
merde tu as pas dit maman la soirée est
finie tu peux venir me chercher dans la
voiture avec ta mère est-ce que tu as
dit qu'il y avait une grosse maman il
s'est passé deux trois petits trucs
graves je t'en parlerai demain quand
j'irai mieux et le lendemain petit
déjeuner elle lui expliqué forcément
elle t'a dit quoi
voilà voilà bravo
qu'on kiffe ta mère elle est où
d'ailleurs là elle est chez moi t'as pas
ramené merde je l'adore Nathalie je veux
te voir tu es incroyable donc elle t'a
dit vous avez déconner à la maison vous
pouvez pas c'est normal le maire il
arrive il va pas vous dire s'il vous
plaît vous pouvez arrêter c'est le
bordel il voit des gars qui se pousse
tout ça il arrive il dit les gars on
arrête tout je vais appeler la police
vous allez dégager au début c'est normal
qu'ils soient agressif je te jure mais
c'est sûr moi je t'aime beaucoup tu es
sympa tu vois mais là c'est normal il
arrive il a la gueule en biais il est
défoncé
alors avant ce que je vais dire je
précise quand même qu'il y a deux
majeurs qui sont mis en examen
judiciaire c'est grave c'est ce qu'il
dit evan et c'est ce qu'elle dit
Nathalie violence aggraver menace de
mort à personne dépositaire de
l'autorité c'est grave il y a un mineur
qui a été identifié et là ce soir il y a
une quatrième personne en cours
d'identification maintenant ce que je
vais dire Cyril c'est que c'est vrai la
justice s'interroge et le témoignage là
il corroborent certaines informations
que j'ai la justice se demande pourquoi
un maire qui alors je vais dire aurait
été tabassé par plusieurs jeunes on a eu
15 jours 10 TT et 2% d'amis question de
la justice deuxième question d'injustice
est-ce qu'il n'en fait pas un peu
beaucoup puisque quand les gendarmes
sont prévenus il était sympa quand il
est venu absolument mais il est très
sympa et Jean-Paul conditionnel les
gendarmes viennent et n'alerte
l'autorité judiciaire par texto que le
dimanche matin on me dit c'est que si ça
avait été très grave vous alerter dans
la nuit la fluji a été comment genre une
fluogie comme ça aux gens une bonne
folie comme ça une bonne quand même ah
quand même mais
[Rires]
la police elle est arrivée les deux
personnes qui sont partis en garde à vue
ils sont pas partis en garde à vue parce
qu'ils avaient tapé le maire à la base
eux ils partent juste parce que le mec
était déjà parti quand la police est
arrivée donc ils sont partis pourquoi et
bah eux ils sont partis parce que avec
l'alcool machin truc
je t'explique
Evan tu as raison moi je la version du
maire c'est à peu près la même Evan a
deux petits trucs près je suis désolé
les mecs elle est pas c'est pas non plus
complètement une autre version un amour
d'être venu Evan moi je suis paumé un
truc tu as pas le temps moi c'est ta
mère vous allez faire un kiff au mer
vous voyez c'est que vos potes vous le
racheter des deux paires de tombes et
vous l'envoyer
n'oublie toute cette histoire
et la prochaine fois moi je t'inviterai
à mon anniversaire d'accord sans alcool
mais il est très sympathique en tout cas
merci mon chéri